more than 470 000 americans have lost
their lives to covet 19 and
just under 5 000 of those deaths are
from here in clark county
so as we enter now year two of the
pandemic
thousands of others who've gotten sick
and survived are realizing that a full
recovery may be elusive
many battle a wide range of health
problems that is baffling doctors
fear and frustration in the face of
cobit
my chest hurts my back hurts my stomach
when i cough
spring 2020 nahama kravitz knocked down
by a bug
besides the obvious physical signs her
mental state wasn't right
i was on the phone with one of the
people on my team at work
and i couldn't remember words there were
words that i couldn't remember
one day i was taking a shower and i
could not breathe i had to kick the
shower open and i just passed out on the
floor and that's when i went back to the
hospital
carla washington and kravitz are just
two of the thousands of people
suffering from symptoms weeks and even
months later
there's a few terms for it post-covet
syndrome
long-covered long-hauler syndrome
dr silhan specializes in internal and
pulmonary medicine
she estimates about 10 percent of cobit
patients are what are now being called
long-haulers the most common are
breathlessness
exercising tolerance fatigue
some chest pain cough
she had all the official signs but the
diagnosis couldn't validate it
so when you got your test and it came
back negative
what was your reaction a part of me was
devastated to be honest the positive
test would have confirmed what she was
feeling
without it she felt lost i had a few
patients who
had mild to moderate symptoms for the
first two weeks and then week three
they were completely negative but then
they're actually sicker starting week
three this is a new thing we're seeing
the virus is unpredictable and
unforgiving
people who were seemingly healthy with
no underlying health conditions have
their bodies turn on them
suffering with long covet this is
seeming to happen
at least in my experience to people who
are otherwise extremely healthy and
young
in some the immune system just falls
apart
in others organs are targeted heart
failure
kidney disease are not uncommon but the
symptoms for a long hauler
swing so widely it's tough to nail down
it's been trying to figure out why i'm
having all these symptoms and
not getting a lot of answers although
there may not be clear answers there is
a community both women found it on
facebook by joining support groups
this is a real thing these are these are
people who are
all over the world who are writing about
the same exact symptoms
okay so i'm not crazy this is really
real like
you know i'm really not back to where i
am and other people
are going through the same thing
thousands of people worldwide and in
december congress authorized funding for
more research to study the prolonged
health consequences of long covet
it's a big enough problem that post
covid 19 care and rehab centers have now
opened at hospitals all across the
country